ist sie für 2024 geplante mondlandung
der nasa ein großer schwindel gestern
gelangte ein geheimes dokument der
weltraumagentur an die öffentlichkeit
dass zweifel aufkommen lässt hat die
nasa also nicht die wahrheit gesagt und
ist das projekt so gar nicht umsetzbar
pixum science fiction jetzt täglich
faszinierendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen mitte mai kündigte
die nasa für 2024 an auf dem mond zu
landen und eine frau soll dieses mal den
ersten schritt auf den mond machen
werden hier darüber berichtet bei dieser
ersten von einer reihe von missionen
soll am südpol nach wasser für eine
dauerhafte mondstation besucht werden
doch jetzt wurde ein internes dokument
der nasa veröffentlicht das zweifel sät
denn dieser plan und die realität
klaffen weit auseinander
das fängt schon mit der vorgesehenen
rakete an dem space launch system sls
das sollte nicht nur schon 2017 seinen
ersten testflug absolvieren
das soll jetzt 2020 passieren das
projekt gerät auch finanziell vollkommen
aus den fugen bisher kosten bau und
entwicklung pro jahr drei milliarden
dollar starts dieser rakete dürften dann
in zukunft so etwa um die eine milliarde
dollar kosten zum vergleich der start
der aktuell größten rakete der welt
kostet maximal 150 millionen dollar
der falcon heavy es gibt zurzeit keine
vergleichbaren raketen sondern dass man
die kosten mit der delta vier
vergleichen muss bei der felten heavy
kostet der transport eines kilogramms
nutzlast in eine niedrige erdumlaufbahn
rund 2350 dollar bei der kelter vier
heavy sind es rund 13.900 dollar also
mehr als fünfmal so teuer und es gibt
noch ein weiteres problem für eine
mondlandung müsste die sls rakete noch
einmal verbessert werden sonst kommt sie
einfach nicht zum mond doch im nasa
budget entwurf für 2020 wurde diese
version gestrichen und auch für die
mondlandefähre gibt es bisher noch kein
geld aus dem jetzt gelegten plan geht
ein finanzieller mehrbedarf von
mindestens sechs bis acht milliarden
dollar pro jahr hervor aber tatsächlich
soll die nasa mehr geld bekommen 1,6
milliarden pro jahr
das reicht also hinten und vorne nicht
und selbst das ist noch nicht sicher
das geld soll nämlich einem fonds
entnommen werden der bedürftigen
studierenden dabei helfen soll dass
teure universitätsstudium in den usa
überhaupt bezahlen zu können
ob das so eine gute idee ist der
kongress muss diesen plan erst noch
zustimmen
und das ist überhaupt noch nicht sicher
aber selbst wenn das geld und sogar der
mehrbedarf zusammenkommen sollten
erinnert derzeit bahn er an die
vollmundigen ankündigungen von ihnen
maske er hat bisher nahezu jedes datum
gerissen außer der fertigstellung des
batterie speichers in australien da hat
er wirklich pünktlich abgeliefert aber
die nasa will jetzt mit einer noch nicht
budgetierten weiterentwicklung einer
noch nie gestarteten rakete und weiteren
kommerziellen raketen in den nächsten
zehn jahren 37 starts absolvieren die
raumstation deep space gateway soll in
einen mond ehrt orbit gebracht werden
und eine dauerhafte mondstation soll
gebaut werden also tatsächlich hört sich
das er nach einem märchen als nach einem
realistischen plan an mehr informationen
zu diesem lied gibt es hierbei raumzeit
block der zukunft drauf klicken
anschauen und natürlich abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran